you're from the bronx right yes sir
uptown uptown baby shout out to the
bronx hey man uh
the bronx is like one of those boroughs
that doesn't get enough love all things
considered it's where hip-hop was
birthed it is
literally where hip-hop started in fact
you know um i think like obviously some
of the greatest rappers of all time come
out to brock shout out to punch out the
carrots one
um yeah joey crack but like i feel like
lately like you know ron tuno is doing
his thing
of course hey boogies of course man
shout out to hybrids but like in general
do you feel like the bronx has somehow
become like the most slept on bro in new
york uh easily like and it's weird
because it's where hip hop started yeah
but um you know brooklyn was making
noise for a while queen is outside you
know zayn harlem was definitely harlem
was always going to harlem um i feel
like the bronx just slept on for a while
but i feel like we got it's it's back
we're back i'm not gonna lie in terms of
the spotlight we always had the vibe we
just needed to spot like
now you got it yeah yeah definitely a
great energy uptown right now